Oh God
who's not attractive it really does look
like human but that's me and my boss
opening up a lava lamp oh we're getting
these noise guys our goal was simple to
figure out what's inside as it turned
out it actually wasn't simple at all and
that's because companies don't want you
to know it's a formula that you know has
been pretty well guarded throughout time
you know that's Brian Quetzal vice
president of product development at
Schilling the manufacturers of lava
brand lava lamps and true to his word he
wouldn't share the full recipe but he
did reveal some key ingredients inside
of a lava lamp
you've got wax which is mostly paraffin
wax at shilada paraffin wax is a common
wax made from petroleum you can often
find it in candles and cosmetics but
when we squeezed it in our hands it
didn't really feel like melted wax at
all and what about all that liquid
cattle said it's mostly water and since
wax doesn't mix with water that makes a
lot of sense but as you can see it's not
just water yes that extra coloring is
partly for effect but it also contains
chemicals that prevent fungus from
growing in the bottles and of course he
did leave some things out there's a
little inside there but essentially it's
liquid it's it's water and wax that
quote magic is actually really important
because it's what makes lava lamps work
the way they do you have these two
liquids that are separate but now you
also want to have this effect where the
one of the liquid sort of dance around
and goes up and down and that has to do
with the density he says the density is
everything when it comes to lava lamps
when the lamp is off the wax is slightly
denser than
liquid around it and that's why it sits
at the bottom and when most materials
warm up they expand and become less
dense or lighter that's what causes the
wax to rise and then when it reaches the
top farther from the heat source it
cools contracts gains density and
eventually falls back down so what does
this have to do with what's inside
well regular wax is normally lighter not
heavier than water so then what sort of
wax is this stuff I suspect what you
have inside is in fact not just plain
wax most likely what you have is a
mixture of wax and some additives you
add a little bit of this additive until
it just starts to fall down and that is
when you reach that sweet spot and now
you can use a temperature to tilt the
balance either one side or the other and
so I suspect most of the trademark
secret is what kind of additive you want
to add we asked castle about this and he
said it lava those additives are
actually in the liquid not the wax at
the end you know you do a little bit of
tweaking to the liquid to make sure that
the wax is more dense than the liquid we
may never know for sure what those
special additives are but a study
published in 1996 may hold a clue
the researchers report they found that
one lamp of an unspecified brand
contained kerosene which Sakana
confirmed could make the liquid less
dense but whatever those magical
additives are they smelled really bad
not planar they're not helping the smell
as it turns out so suffice it to say we
won't be opening another lamp anytime
soon and according to the company
neither should you